so for anybody in my audience who maybe
just maybe was getting slightly
complacent about the november
presidential election because the polls
just look so
good for joe biden this is a red alert
moment for you it should be a wake-up
call to
every one of us that nothing is over
this is going to be a huge fight donald
trump could certainly win
we could be facing four more years of a
trump presidency according to data
provided to axios by
yes the trump campaign and the rnc
republicans have more registered voters
than democrats in some key states
relative
to 2016. and i'll tell you i've looked
at the data and it's a mess
now as a pretext not as a pretext as a
um as a disclaimer i think better said
they may be lying so i'm going to give
you the data that axios was given by the
trump campaign and by the rnc
about voter registration they could be
lying if they're lying
great then we'll win by a lot okay but
if they're not lying we need to take
this seriously and that's why this
matters so the point here is
all we can do because we don't know what
the truth is
is register every voter convince every
voter to vote
make sure every vote is counted we've
got to work on this at all levels but
here's what was given to axios
by the trump campaign and the rnc
compared to the numbers that axios was
given by the democratic party and
if this is wrong great but we have to at
least for now assume that this is
accurate
in florida the democratic
registration advantage over republicans
was reduced
by 87 000 registered voters since 2016.
now think back to 2016. trump won
florida by 112
000 votes okay if indeed now
the party registration advantage for
democrats has shrunk
by nearly 90 000 voters that is almost
twice that is almost equivalent to that
would almost double donald trump's
victory margin in 2016. however
new registrations are favoring democrats
so what this means is you've had
people who move in and out of the state
people who switch
party etc among simply
new registrations democrats are winning
but when you account for all of the
other changes in registration
democrats have actually fallen behind in
florida okay
pennsylvania pennsylvania is a state
that donald trump won by 44 000 in 2016
and the democratic advantage in voter
registration has been reduced
by 133 000
voters since 2016. again trump won by 44
000
democrats relative to republicans have
lost 133
000 voters since 2016. important
among new registrations democrats have a
15-point advantage but again because of
moving
deaths um changing
of party etc the advantage has been
reduced by 133 000
in arizona republicans have taken the
advantage in registered voters over
democrats
in iowa republicans have taken advantage
and registered voters over democrats and
in north carolina
the democratic net advantage has shrunk
this is why overwhelming the vote is the
necessary action here if they're going
to suppress the vote well let's
overwhelm
the vote so that suppressing it 0.05 but
you know point five or one percent won't
make a difference
uh they win over uh they win over
democrats in terms of new registrations
or in terms of people who
overwhelm the ballot box right it is
truly the solution here to all of the
problems now another really important
thing
um when you look at new registrations
and see the democratic advantage so for
example imagine that in a certain state
the republicans were able to increase
their advantage in terms of party
registration by a hundred thousand
but among new voters who were never
previously registered democrats
registered more new people my guess
is that the new registrants are more
likely to vote because
something got them to register since the
last election
so maybe that's in our in our corner to
our advantage but you can't assume
anything now there are a few funny
caveats here but again they shouldn't
change our behavior number one
some of the people changing registration
to the republican party
they might be doing it in order to mess
with the republican party we've seen
people
switch to the democratic party to vote
in the democratic primary even though
they have no intention of actually
voting for the democrat in a general
election we've seen it the other way
we don't know for sure but it is
possible that there are people switching
to republican registration
for a variety of different reasons many
of which might not mean they are
necessarily voting for trump in november
we don't know we can't do anything about
it
and again we are evaluating
registration based on the data given to
axios
by the trump campaign and the republican
party they could be lying
they lie all the time it wouldn't be
hugely surprising if they were lying
but we can't know that right now and we
won't know it
until the election if at all so we can't
act on that basis
all we can act on all that we should be
motivated to do
is to keep going and assume nothing
going into november
every single voter i i apologize i know
i say this a lot every single voter
should act as if their vote could turn
your state from one candidate to the
other that's how i will be voting in
massachusetts although certainly
mathematically
it's not going to be the case if you
love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video